falls die Folge 1 bis 4 verpasst habt
schaut die am besten zuerst nachdem es
für mich als erstes an die Küste von
Lagos in Portugal ging ich von dort aus
weiter nach Valencia gereist dann mit
dem Boot auf die Balearen Insel
Formentera gefahren und von dort aus
weiter zum Loch Ness in Schottland
geflogen bin steht nun die fünfte
Episode von reisemonopoly in Reallife an
ich bin schon gespannt wo ich lande und
wünsche euch viel Spaß bei diesem Video
und damit was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut wir
müssen das hier so dunkel ich befinde
mich hier gerade noch im Hotelzimmer im
Inverness kennt ihr sicherlich noch aus
dem letzten Part falls ihr den noch
nicht gesehen habt checken auf jeden
Fall zuerst ab
sauber machen für mich soll's allerdings
heute weitergehen und ich bin mal
gespannt wohin deswegen es ist an der
Zeit Monopoly travel Brettchen
Spielbrett so würfelspielfigur Karten
auch da ich weiß jetzt wo war ich denn
eigentlich Scheiße Moment ich war auf
diesem Ereignisfeld ein vor Ruin von
Hampi ich möchte auch mal die Karten
kurz durch das habe ich nämlich noch nie
gemacht
[Musik]
sag reicht das kann nicht so gut mischen
impossible
[Applaus]
schon wieder eine 11 Digger ich glaube
das ist die dritte elf einfach oder 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 es ist schon wieder
ereignissfeld okay was haben wir
springen in einen Zug und schau wohin er
dich bringt rücke vor auf die nächste
freie Sehenswürdigkeit okay muss ich
sagen finde ich eigentlich ganz gut das
heißt wir werden heute erstmal Zug
fahren und nicht fliegen Zug fahren bin
ich jetzt auch noch nicht in der Serie
glaube ich oder also zumindest nicht
aktiv und man ein neues Ziel zu kommen
ich befinde mich ja gerade in Schottland
und hier gibt's auch auf jeden Fall noch
andere Sachen zu sehen oder andere
richtig coole Städte die ich mir gerne
mal angucken würde und die vor allem
auch ein viel größeren Flughafen haben
weil Inverness der Flughafen ist Mini
klein ich glaube hier landen vielleicht
fünf Flugzeuge am Tag deswegen ist das
ganz gut und danach müssen wir Vorrücken
auf die nächste Sehenswürdigkeit und
Davidstern hingehen und damit Leute was
geht ich habe im Hotel ausgecheckt und
befinde mich jetzt gerade noch im
Zentrum von Inverness ist auf jeden Fall
ganz nett hier wobei ich diesen Teil
jetzt gestern auch gar nicht gesehen
habe nur was wirklich ziemlich lustig
ist also es regnet wirklich so alle 10
Minuten mal und dann regnet es wieder 10
Minuten nicht
regnet es wieder dann kommen wieder die
Sonne raus also das Wetter spielt hier
noch mehr verrückt als in Deutschland
auf jeden Fall laufe ich jetzt hier
gerade zum Bahnhof der müsste auch
gleich schon kommen ich habe mir nämlich
mal die scottische Bahn App geholt also
DB App für Schottland die heißt Scott
Rail die drei größten Städte in
Schottland sind ja einmal Aberdeen
Edinburgh und Glasgow und es gibt aber
generell in ganz Schottland ziemlich
gutes baden oder Schienenverkehrs dazu
habe ich den Eindruck die Hauptroute
führt von Aberdeen über Edinburg nach
Glasgow und mein Plan ist jetzt erstmal
von innen wenn es nach Edinburg zu
fahren und dann könnte ich noch
weiterfahren das Glasgow aber ich habe
jetzt erstmal nur für 60 € den ersten
weg von Inverness nach Edinburgh gebucht
das soll auch eigentlich so die schönste
Stadt in Schottland sein und ja deswegen
stehe ich jetzt hier
Scott rail
und da müssen wir sein könnte auch
Duisburg Hauptbahnhof sein oder nicht
Entschuldigung mal gucken wie Bahn
fahren in Schottland funktioniert ob die
Dinger hier pünktlich sind
[Musik]
and one
das hier ist übrigens die App und so
sieht dann mein Ticket aus ja und hier
haben wir die Anzeigetafel ich muss erst
in den ersten Zug nach Stirling und da
muss ich dann umsteigen und fahre nach
Edinburg ja das ist auf jeden Fall der
Plan dann warte ich jetzt mal auf die
gleichen Information okay es ist
Plattform 2 jetzt bewegt sich auch alles
alle stehen auf und gehen los ich muss
aber erster sein Weg da Plattform
okay da muss ich jetzt erst durch mit
meinem Code okay das hat schon mal
optimal funktioniert jetzt geht's hier
in den Zug der ist auch echt richtig
lang ich habe auch ein fest zugewiesenen
Platz Wagen 4 Platz 9a der war im Preis
mit drin muss ich also nicht extra
reservieren und ja
das sagt mir sogar was ist das auch ein
Nachtzug oder wie okay es ist doch nicht
die sondern der aber irgendwie haben die
Gleise noch mal gewechselt okay
dadurch dass ich ja wirklich extrem viel
in letzter Zeit gereist bin versuche ich
natürlich auch unterwegs wenn ich
zuklage oder Fliege manchmal Eindrücke
festzuhalten aber das kann man halt
nicht fünf Stunden durchgehen machen
wenn man durchgehend in dem Zug oder im
Flugzeug sitzt und ich liebe einfach
geile Podcasts und da freue ich mich
dass ich euch einmal ganz kurz Podium
vorstellen darf und wie ihr polymop
Premium 2 Monate komplett kostenlos
nutzen können ist eine App auf der
mehrere hunderte exklusive Podcasts und
über 25
000 Hörbücher gibt die euch perfekt im
Bus im Zug im Flugzeug im Urlaub wo auch
immer reinziehen können mein lieblings
exklusiv Podcast von podimo ist Reise in
den Tod dort geht es um True Crime Fälle
die im Urlaub passieren sehr
empfehlenswert und wenn ihr euch über
den ersten in der Videobeschreibung bei
polimo anmeldet bekommt ihr das ganze 2
Monate kostenlos 60 Tage zu testen und
wir fahren jetzt weiter Zug
auf jeden Fall Zug und ähm ist es doch
nicht normal dass die Reservierung dabei
ist das auf jeden Fall mein Platz 9a auf
jeden Fall noch mal gespannt wie so die
Umgebung hier aussieht weil die
Landschaften ist jetzt mal hier einsa
wird bestimmt eine schöne Zugfahrt
[Musik]
während ich Zug gefahren bin habe ich
natürlich auch versucht mir ein Hotel zu
buchen und mir ist aufgefallen edinburgh
ist noch mal teurer als Inverness das
günstigste war ein 3-Sterne-Hotel mit
6,7 sternenbewertung das ist wirklich
nicht gut für 192 Euro die Nacht ich
habe es versucht zu buchen ging aber
nicht oder musste ich weitersuchen okay
Leute erste drei Stunden Zugfahrt hinter
mir ich bin jetzt angekommen hier in
sterling und hier muss ich jetzt 20
Minuten warten auf den nächsten Zug der
bringt mich dann nach Edinburgh wieder
nicht ganz nett aus hier werden euch
einmal rum ein sehr sauberer und
entspannter Bahnhof fast so sauber wie
in Deutschland also Zug fahren hier in
Schottland funktioniert auf jeden Fall
problemlos und alles pünktlich bis jetzt
die Züge da vorne auf der Anzeige habe
ich schon noch alle one time das einzige
Problem was ich habe mein Handy ist fast
gleich ich habe noch 3% und ich habe
immer noch kein Adapter weil im Zug kann
ich auch nur mit diesem Adapter Laden
mein Ticket ist halt nur auf dem Handy
naja wird schon irgendwie klappt und ich
habe auch ein richtig verrücktes Hotel
gebucht das muss ich euch gleich mal
erklären super komisch das kostet
eigentlich irgendwie 500 € pro Nacht
aber war jetzt halt am günstigsten ich
hoffe ich wurde nicht gescammt wir
werden sehen okay Leute gleich endlich
geschafft
desto flacher wird es wir sind jetzt
aber auch schon glaube ich zumindest
okay Leute angekommen Edinburg endlich
muss jetzt auf jeden Fall in diese
Richtung irgendwo und dann bin ich
wirklich mal verdammt gespannt auf mein
Hotel da sind wir Edinburgh
erste Eindruck ist auch wieder sehr
verrückt also gerade auf die Gebäude und
die Straße geht da einfach so hoch naja
also mein Hotel ist auf jeden Fall
irgendwo da oben aber jetzt muss ich
erstmal hier die Straße hoch oder den
Weg und das sind noch ein paar Treppen
ey wo bin ich hier gelandet Jingle Jordi
was oben angekommen
[Musik]
dahin muss ich ich weiß nicht ob man es
sehen kann aber da ganz hinten ist
einfach das Meer die Nordsee hier sind
anscheinend auch so komisch drin aber da
unten die Hausaufgaben
gar nichts hier egal
[Musik]
ich würde aber lieber auf mein Zimmer
muss ich sagen
hier gelandet WTF ich komme nicht klar
ich habe gerade auch überhaupt nichts
verstanden was sie mir erzählt hat aber
ich habe einfach mal jetzt gesagt
irgendwas mit da kommen will Cookies
raus oder so hier aus dieser Tür ich
weiß gar nicht ob ihr mich überhaupt
sehen könnt ist so dunkel hier alles
halt ist das hier für den Laden oh nein
irgendwie sieht's aus wie so ein Bordell
oder oh sogar ein Brief Hausaufgaben
hier 5,50€
Utopien Fantasy morning nun online die
Hausaufgaben
irgendwie interessantes Konzept Zimmer
ist Arsch klein in Edinburg ist zurzeit
Hochsaison das heißt alle Hotels sind
mega ausgebucht und eigentlich wollte
ich in so einem drei Sterne Hotel für
240 € die Nacht das war dann weg und
dann ist dieses Ding aufgeploppt mit
einer viel besseren Bewertung für 289 €
habe ich bekommen aber eigentlich kostet
es pro Nachteile euch fest über 500 €
für das ohne Witz ich brennt euch immer
ein kurz zu Erklärung als ich Edinburgh
war war dort das the Royal Edinburgh
Military Tattoo das ist das größte
Musikfestival Schottlands und das war
auf jeden Fall der größte Indikator für
diese hohen Hotelpreise ich mache mir
jetzt auf jeden Fall auf dem Weg nach
draußen vorher gebe ich euch noch eine
kurz roomtour von diesem verrückten
Hotelzimmer irgendwie ist alles hier
komisch keine Ahnung warum hier in
Franken ist der nicht mal ganz zugeht
wofür ich glaube das ist einfach nur
Dekoration das ist das Bett habt ihr
schon gesehen und hier ist einfach die
mini bar ja moinsen hier kann ich
klingeln dann kommt anscheinend Kaffee
habe ich jetzt noch nicht probiert und
hier kommen Cookies raus sobald ich das
verstanden habe wenn irgendwas ist kann
ich hier drauf drücken ja das Badezimmer
ist relativ klein gehalten hallo und
dann was ist das auch schon mit der
Phänomen Tour das Hotel nennt sich die
House of God irgendwas also falls Sie
mal in Edinburg sein solltet und
Multimillionär seid könnt ihr hier
hingehen oder man hat einfach ein
bisschen Glück bei der Buchung so jetzt
geht's raus in die City okay gut ich bin
hier direkt zentral das muss man sagen
ach so eine Sache die ich noch vergessen
habe das habe ich gerade gefunden das
hier ist der magische Knopf
aha ja ja also was hier alles schon
passiert ist und wer hier eigentlich so
schläft will ich gar nicht wissen ich
glaube wirklich nur verrückte Menschen
nee nicht verrückt offen man muss ja
immer aufpassen was man sagt
schön hier
ja ja also das hatte ja alles ganz
komisch
ja gut okay Leute ich bin auf jeden Fall
jetzt auf den streets unterwegs mein
erstes Ziel ist da hinten diese Burg von
da soll man sehr schön Ausblick über
Edinburgh haben und da gehe ich jetzt
mal hin weil jetzt gleich geht auch
schon die Sonne unter und ich will ja
noch was sehen irgendwie sind hier super
viele so
Straßen zum Beispiel
alle
mehr was anderes das ist in Edinburg
anscheinend sehr beliebt so hier haben
wir die nächste
Gryffindor ist auf jeden Fall auch hier
wurde hier irgendwie zufällig Harry
Potter gedreht das könnte sein oder wow
Leute schaut euch das mal an da oben
will ich eigentlich jetzt hin aber wie
komme ich da hoch es sieht wirklich aus
wie Harry Potter ne und da oben spielen
die creditch
it was
okay
Leute leider kommt man da heute nicht
hoch weil da jetzt irgendwie ein Konzert
ist zumindest da oben und dafür will ich
mir jetzt natürlich nicht extra Tickets
kaufen weil ich bin jetzt nicht hier um
ihren Konzert reinzuziehen nur natürlich
schade weil das war top eins der
Sehenswürdigkeiten und da oben wäre
schon gern mal hingegangen aber ich
schau mal ob ich vielleicht doch einen
anderen Aussichtspunkt finde ich habe
noch einen anderen Aussichtspunkt
gefunden da gehen wir jetzt gleich
meinen aber erstmal gibt's noch eben
schnell was zu essen weil ich habe
übelst Hunger und natürlich teste dich
den besten Burger in Edinburg muss ja
sein okay und hier sind wir auch schon
red meets Brad bester Laden ich hoffe es
geht jetzt ein place
[Musik]
so Leute Burger ist angekommen bin mal
gespannt okay Leute ich habe aufgegessen
der Burger war auf jeden Fall super
lecker 8,5 von 10 war ja ein
Cheeseburger mir hat da ein bisschen
Salat und Tomate gefehlt aber egal ich
bin ja kein food Youtuber auf jeden Fall
ist es jetzt eigentlich schon dunkel
geworden hier in Edinburg wir gehen
jetzt aber trotzdem noch zum
Aussichtspunkt und eine Sache die ich
noch mal loswerden muss ich checke nicht
in keinem Top Ten Ranking der teuersten
Städte der Welt ist irgendeine Stadt aus
Schottland drin aber es hat mich gerade
einfach 26 € gekostet der Burger die
Preis und das Getränk in Oslo habe ich
weniger bezahlt und Oslo ist irgendwie
Platz 2 oder 3 keine Ahnung wie geht das
also wenn ihr nach Schottland wollt
stellt euch auf dem teuren Aufenthalt
ein und jetzt kann ich auch endlich
wieder am Laptop arbeiten und auch meine
Kamera wieder aufladen weil die ist leer
und ohne den hätte ich ein Problem
großes Problem Leute ich habe gerade
hier eine Bar gesehen die hinter mir
Nummer 64 da gehe ich jetzt rein
deswegen irgendwie cool aus und wenn ich
jetzt gelandet kann man einfach zocken
und was trinken
da kann man jetzt auf jeden Fall ein
Spiel spielen was ich jetzt gerade mal
gemacht habe
[Musik]
bei mir ist alles nur zwei Ideen
ich habe kurz in den Spieletag
[Musik]
so die wahre auf jeden Fall cool jetzt
geht es aber zum Aussichtspunkt ich weiß
nicht ganz ob ich hier richtig bin
irgendwie
ist hier niemand außer mir sehr gruselig
auch ne was ist das hier ja ja die
nächste Kirche aber ich gehe einfach mal
weiter
[Musik]
ich hoffe es ist nun Feuerwerk aber ich
gehe mal davon aus dass bei diesem music
festival da Feuerwerk startet
vielleicht finden wir es heraus ich muss
da hoch Rennen und dann bin ich
eigentlich schon da
wir kommentiert ja immer ob ich Angst
habe wenn ich alleine irgendwo Hinreise
eigentlich nicht denn man muss auch
sagen ach guck mal hier sind noch andere
Leute ich glaube es wird sich lohnen wow
Alter
ein bisschen leid dass ich meine große
Kamera nicht dabei mit dem Leister
Objektiv aber der Blick ist schon geil
es sieht natürlich mit richtigen Augen
die ich ja besitze komischerweise noch
mal viel geiler aus Neustadt ehrlich
mal eine Minute eher hier gewesen noch
gesehen das cool ist Leute mein Hotel
ist genau da und hier ist die größte Bar
da gehe ich jetzt noch rein und dann ich
schlafen
[Musik]
okay Leute wieder zurück in meinem
erotischen Zimmer hier ich gehe auf
jeden Fall jetzt schlafen das war ein
schöner Abend in Edinburgh wir haben
jetzt auch schon 1 Uhr kurzes Fazit zur
Stadt also das was ich bis jetzt gesehen
habe war wirklich ziemlich geil also
Edinburgh hat mich voll und ganz
überzeugt es ist eine sehr hügelige
Stadt und du bist manchmal ganz oben und
manchmal auch relativ weit unten und
muss dann wieder irgendwohin hochrennen
nur natürlich mein Hotel ist jetzt auch
in der Altstadt und die Altstadt ist
wirklich super touristisch das ist aber
eigentlich ein was jeder dazu die eine
bedeutende Altstadt hat und auch gerade
weil hier dieses Musikfestival ist
irgendwie das heißt Tattoo Edinburg oder
so habe ich nicht ganz verstanden was
das mit dem Tattoo zu tun aber deswegen
ist es hier wohl gerade auch noch mal
voller als sonst nichts ist zu trotz
eine sehr Multikulti statt also super
viele Nationen die hier entweder
touristisch sind oder gar sogar leben
weil sie nicht gerade in dem Pub wo ich
noch war aber wirklich super viele
verschiedene Kulturen die so irgendwie
aufeinander gepasst sind hatte ich das
Gefühl also bis hierhin Edinburg einen
Burger regnet es eigentlich Edinburgh
oder Edinburgh aus ich glaube er den
irgendwann in der Schule ich hoffe das
Video hat euch bis hierhin gefallen
wahrscheinlich geht's morgen noch weiter
es könnte aber auch sein dass das dann
alles schon in der sechsten Folge landet
weil die sechste Folge soll noch mal
richtig geil werden ist ja auch wie ich
so angekündigt habe dann die letzte
Folge heute abonniert sehr gerne den
Kanal schon mal und ich gehe jetzt
erstmal schlafen machen erstmal das rote
Licht hier wieder aus ja wollen wir
eigentlich ganz entspannt mit ich
wünsche euch eine traumhafte Nacht